with a whole universe of things to learn
it's important to start with the
essentials let's go over the concepts
that make kubernetes usable scalable and
just downright awesome are you ready
hello i'm kazen fields i'm a developer
advocate at google cloud where i focus
on kubernetes and google kubernetes
engine today we're going to be
demonstrating what it's like to get
hands-on with some kubernetes essentials
and to guide us we have an expert
anthony bouchon anthony would you
introduce yourself yeah happy too thanks
for having me here counseling my name is
anthony bouchan i'm a specialist
customer engineer at google focused on
working with users who are trying to run
kubernetes
on gke in production
wow so you must have some really cool
insights into how this stuff works in
the real world
so i'm really excited to see what you're
going to teach us today
definitely just trying to build on the
concepts that you and carter have
introduced
in previous episodes of kubernetes
essentials specifically we're going to
take a look at how you can
work with namespaces and services when
something is going wrong with the
deployment of your application in
kubernetes they each have respective
properties that we can take a look at to
help us debug and help us remediate
whatever issue we're resolving or we're
running into in our kubernetes
environment cool so what are we going to
start out with well
for starters we're going to have a
sample application running in a
kubernetes cluster and that sample
application is comprised of a front-end
pod
which is fronted by a service type load
balancer so we have a public ip address
so we can access it in a browser and
that front-end pod is communicating with
a back-end pod
and so the back-end pod is returning a
whole bunch of information
and metadata about the environment in
which it's running and we can actually
see here these specific requests that
the front end is issuing to the back-end
if we take a look at the kubernetes
manifest we'll see here that
they are both represented by deployments
and they each reside within their own
specific name spaces so in this specific
scenario we have the front end that is
managed by team a running in namespace
team a and then we have uh the backend
application which is owned by team b
running in namespace team b cool so here
we have a website
which has a front end and a back end and
those the the front end and the back end
are each owned by separate teams
and those teams are utilizing different
name spaces
so what are we going to look into next
well
we're going to take a look at
the namespaces a bit further so so that
we can understand what constraints could
actually be defined at the namespace
level that might actually affect the
deployment of our pods and applications
so as you can see namespaces are a great
way to divide the resources within a
given cluster across various teams and
namespaces give you a lot of control
between what you can actually
access within a given cluster
so as you can see here that we have
the front end is owned by team a and we
have a namespace called team a
and then we have uh the back end which
is owned by team b and it's in the
namespace team b cool so let's take a
deeper look at these namespaces so when
digging into the name spaces within a
given cluster it can often be a bit
difficult to navigate uh and understand
which namespace you're working against
so the cuban s tool is a great tool to
show all the namespaces in your cluster
as well as which one your kubernetes
context is currently configured to
interact with
once we know what namespace we're
working with team b in this case we can
run commands like troops detail auth can
i
and define the verbs and resources that
we want to interact with so if we want
to delete or create
let's say pods we want to be able to
check and ensure that we can actually
interact with these resources in that
given namespace
and so once that we have verified that
we have permissions to the namespace to
interact with the resources we need to
we can actually describe the namespace
and take a look at some of the
constraints that are defined at a
namespace level the first one is
resource quotas so
if it's a great way to limit the
resources that a team can use within a
given kubernetes cluster so in this case
we're defining a pod resource quota
and it's a great use case for trying to
preserve ip allocation across multiple
teams sharing the same kubernetes
cluster so in this case we're ensuring
that this team can only run five pods
which means five ips that it will
consume
we also want to define resource limits
basically these are just
range limit ranges that define
our minimum and maximum amount of cpu
that containers can request uh when
running in this namespace and so great
it's a great place to troubleshoot
because either of these could be reasons
why your deployment fails or why your
deployment is being blocked because
there are constraints in place uh within
that given name space so namespaces give
us a way to
manage and isolate resources on some
basis in this case on a team basis and
there are also controls in there that we
can use to make sure that
all of the resources for that team are
running the way that we expect them to
exactly exactly right like limit ranges
resource quotas these are all things
that could be defined for various teams
role-based access control is a really
good way to not just isolate individual
user access to various resources but
also service accounts that workloads use
if they require different levels of
access
within the cluster as well and this is
just the tip of the iceberg there's also
there are many things that are namespace
scope network policies for example that
can be again different constraints that
are defined for where your workloads run
cool so what are we going to dive into
next so we took a little bit about what
we can do to understand how namespaces
may be affecting our interactions with
kubernetes so the next thing that we're
going to take a look at are kubernetes
services and how we can interact with
them to understand what may be going
wrong with our application running in a
kubernetes cluster
cool so let's take a deeper look at them
happy too so
if we take a look at the front end that
we deployed we can actually see the
host that the front end the hostname
that the front end is actually issuing a
request against which is the
backend service that is owned by team b
and so uh kubernetes services as you've
talked about in the past uh caslin
are a nice abstraction um on top of
kubernetes pods or replicas of a given
pod and so rather than trying to think
about a per pod level we can think about
a service level that maps to numerous
replicas of a pod and it's represented
by the objects you see here pods
services and endpoints
and so when we want to troubleshoot
something locally we can actually port
forward against the service where we
actually are again port forwarding
interactions with our backend to our
local
8080 port
so as you can see here i'm going to
issue a command to localhost
on port 8080
and we're actually going to get a
response directly from our backend that
is running in the team b space so
basically when you're going through the
debugging cycle if you need to interact
with services locally or things that are
a little harder
to visualize with like a web ui or
something like that you can actually
port forward it to your development
workstation and begin to interact with
it on your local host
so services give us a way to interact
with workloads running on kubernetes we
can run our apps in pods
but if you have multiple copies of those
pods then how do you interact with the
workload as a whole and services give us
that
exactly and you get a dns record that
gets provisioned
so again you don't even have to remember
that virtual ip or that cluster ip
address you can actually natively
interact with it
with a dns hostname that gets a dns
record that gets provisioned to cube dns
or your clusters dns
and so it's really useful for again
clients within the cluster to interact
with your application but it's again
also useful for end users trying to
understand what's going on
with the port forward command with
kubectl
nice so where do we go from here
well i we showed a little bit about dns
so you know there's the angel joke about
how it's it's always dns so i think it's
important to understand a bit more about
how we can interact and troubleshoot
with the dns in our kubernetes cluster
all right so let's take a look at it
what have you got to show us when we're
debugging dns so i think the first thing
uh that's important to
capture and understand is where qdns is
actually running within our cluster
so uh we're going to run cubens again
and we're actually going to see a
namespace called cubesystem
and so cubesystem is where system pods
that are required for the cluster to
function like dns
typically reside
so if we actually run cube ctl get pods
and grep for qdns we're going to see a
few pods running two replicas of cube
dns as well as an auto scaler so i think
it's really important to understand you
know as your cluster scales up as your
workload scale up
the number of dns queries also typically
goes up and so typically you want to
make sure that your cube dns pods are
actually scaling up
properly and are able to handle all of
the various
volume of dns queries coming from your
services
and so when something is going wrong if
you take a look at this we've navigated
to a yaml file for a dns utils container
and this is actually giving us a way to
interact with cube dns without having to
package up
tools that we would use to troubleshoot
into our application containers so once
we actually apply the dns utils yaml
file you'll see that this single pod of
called dns utils has been created and
then we're going to
take again just verify what namespace
it's in and so we're going to switch to
cluster utils
uh again a great way to separate uh
tooling we use to troubleshoot from
application workload then we're going to
run the cube ctl exec command and we're
actually going to pass in a couple flags
dash i and dash t and this is basically
a way for us to kick off an interactive
shell within the dns utils pod and the
dns utils pod will have tooling that we
may want to use to troubleshoot dns like
ns lookup
and so um it's also important to know
that while you could you know get the
interactive shell by passing dash in t
you can also just uh execute the single
command if that's as uh you know um
if that's what the use case calls for
and not an interactive shell
so what we're doing here is we're
actually testing the dns resolution for
our backend service so we're using gceme
backend.teamtb and we'll see that we
actually got the cluster ip returned to
us properly
and so once we actually run cube ctl get
service
we'll actually see that this is
the same cluster ip that was returned
from the dns resolution
cool so what you did here is really
interesting you
uh created a new pod within kubernetes
that had these dns utils on it and then
you used that pod to debug what was
going on with dns in the cluster
that's really interesting and gives you
a really nice way to debug what's
happening with dns without even messing
with your other existing applications in
the cluster
yeah exactly right like i think it's it
gives you a safe way to package up a set
of tools that you only need to use for a
specific period of time and then you can
spin it down once you're done
troubleshooting or you've identified the
root cause and i think this really helps
minimize what we actually need to bake
into our application containers and
that's useful for a whole bunch of
reasons whether it's security whether
it's performance there are different a
bunch of different angles and benefits
that we get from making sure that we're
not uh basically causing bloat within
our application containers
so what else do we want to go over today
well i think it was really uh you know
cool to see the exec um
uh functionality within coupe ctl for
our our sort of toolbox or dns utils
container but i also want to show that
this is something that you could do with
your application containers as well so
we'll take a little bit of further look
as to when we would run an exec into our
application containers
so cube ctl exec
great for utilizing with utility or
debugging containers but also can be
used with your application containers as
well
this is useful if you need to take it if
you need to take a look at the
environment in which your application is
running
so if something's going wrong with your
application as it's running in
kubernetes we can use this tool to dive
into them and figure out what's
happening
exactly so just building upon the
example uh that we have in this uh in
this in this video today here we're
gonna take a look at uh we're gonna
switch back to the team b name space and
we're actually going to take a look at
our back end container or our pod here
that's running serving our back end
we're actually going to run the same
cubesat exec command
and we're going to
provide the pod name so in this case
um the back end production pod with a
specific uh
hash at the end and then we're going to
kick off an interactive shell once again
and so this is a way for us to
understand what's going on in our actual
runtime environment so i just ran print
end and i can actually see all the
different environment variables that are
configured within this environment this
container and so it's really useful if
you need to take a peek at things that
might change or want to verify that
things are correct within the actual
container that you're running
and another thing that's interesting
about this is that going back to you
know again the conversation of
creating minimal containers sometimes
you actually won't even have a a running
shell or something that you could
initiate a connection to and so
in those scenarios coupe ctl has
actually added functionality for
mounting a debugging container um into
that running pod right so if you don't
have a running shell there's actually a
relatively new functionality that
enables you to still get that
interactive environment where you can do
things like check environment variables
or other things that might affect your
application
while you're troubleshooting
thanks for that demo anthony you covered
a lot of really cool stuff in there and
a lot of tips and tricks that even i
didn't know
and i really think we're just scratching
the tip of the iceberg here right i
think i just really wanted to take a
look at namespaces and services and some
of the essentials that are important
that you know folks interacting with
kubernetes should be aware of when
trying to figure out when things are
going wrong why they are going wrong and
you know trying to remediate them but of
course there's so much more to to dive
into right today we learned about how
kubernetes namespaces can help you
isolate and manage resources for example
on a per team basis and we learned how
services can help you reach your
workloads and can help you debug them
then we learn some great tips and tricks
for debugging both networking problems
from cube dns and how to get into your
applications to debug them using cubexec
thank you so much for watching if you
want to explore more we'll have links to
additional resources in the description
below and be sure to like and subscribe
for more content from google cloud we'll
see you next time
you